wir müssen uns daran gewöhnen dass diese
nachricht aus deutschland kommt aus
unserem wald das ganze wochenende
diese bilder waldbrände auf einer fläche
so groß wie etwa 700 fußballfelder das
ganze südlich von berlin treuenbrietzen
so heißt dieser kleine ort im wald da
liegt noch ganz viel munition da kann
die feuerwehr also ganz schwer nur
löschen und bildet das kennen sie
vielleicht das ist die spargel region
vor berlin auch dort brennt der wald
genauso die luftwaffe hilft er
inzwischen mit hubschrauber zum löschen
im einsatz eigene löschflugzeuge gibt es
ja gar nicht in deutschland räumpanzer
mittlerweile im einsatz wasserwerfer
also man hat alles was man hat dort auf
gefahren im wald aber es brennt immer
noch seit tagen ein bisschen regen jetzt
in den vergangenen stunden der hat
überhaupt nichts geändert an dieser lage
die rauchschwaden dieser brände die kann
man von der hauptstadt von berlin
aussehen der brandgeruch den riecht man
je nach wind sogar noch im süden in
dresden und diese brände die sind
längste gefahr für die menschen die in
der nähe dieser feuer leben in
brandenburg in den dörfern raus aus den
häusern evakuierung in den letzten
stunden die menschen müssen alles hinter
sich lassen in der hoffnung dass sich
die flammen ihre häuser nicht holen raus
aus den dörfern rhein in notunterkünfte
so lange bis hoffentlich endlich die
verheerenden brände unter kontrolle sind
waldbrände das ist immer noch ein wort
das man eher mit kalifornien oder
südeuropa verbindet waldbrände sind aber
auch hier in brandenburg in deutschland
und wir gehen zu unserer bild reporterin
zu klarer marie becker dort am rande
dieser waldbrände klarer du siehst diese
feuer schilder uns einmal was haben die
für eine kraft
ja wir stehen heute morgen hier in
beelitz die feuer sehen wir jetzt gerade
aktuell nicht weil sie eben hinter
diesen militärischen sicherheitsbereich
liegen in denen wir jetzt gerade noch
nicht rein dürfen denn feuerwehr und
bundeswehr haben sich jetzt hier und
auch die polizei versammelt um neue
absprachen zu treffen man hat darauf
gehofft dass heute nach der regen die
situation etwas entspannt das aber nicht
eingetreten das hat zwar geregnet es
reicht aber noch lange noch nicht aus um
diese rund 200 hektar brennenden wald
zu stoppen und deswegen muss in der sich
natürlich müssen sich die einsatzkräfte
hier vor ort neu sammeln einen neuen
plan für heute machen und genau
überlegen wo sie jetzt als nächstes
zum einsatz kommen wo sie löschen und
das problem ist ja eben hier auch vor
ort sie können ja nicht in die wälder
reinfahren deswegen ist dieser
sicherheitsbereich hinter uns auch eben
abgesperrt denn diese wälder sind
vermint dort liegt noch munition und die
einsatzkräfte können eben nicht rein
fahren um dort vor ort zu löschen sie
müssen vom straßenrand aus löschen sie
müssen mit ja mit aus der luft löschen
und das macht die situation für die
einsatzkräfte natürlich hier vor ort
extrem schwierig hast du den eindruck
klarer dass man alles hat was man
braucht ich hab gerade schon gesagt
löschflugzeuge gibt es in deutschland
jetzt nicht jetzt kann man noch nicht
mal richtig ran und wir haben gerade
während du gesprochen hast diese
hubschrauber gesehen die an badeseen
dort in brandenburg unterwegs waren und
dann quasi eimer für eimer dort das
wasser abgeholt haben also haben die
helfer dort in den wäldern das was sie
brauchen
ja die feuerwehr ist hier mit mehreren
1000 einsatzkräften die polizei ist vor
ort die luftwaffe fliegt über die wälder
also es sind auf jeden fall das
technische hilfswerk haben ja auch hier
gesehen vor ort die bundeswehr ist zur
stelle der wurden wirklich alle kräfte
mobilisiert da haben sich wirklich alle
zusammen getan und eben wie gesagt
besprechen jetzt wie sie den tag weiter
angehen um diese feier einigermaßen im
rahmen ihrer möglichkeiten in den griff
zu bekommen wie viele menschen sind da
jetzt ohne zuhause aktuell wir haben
gerade die bilder von den evakuierungen
dort aus den kleinen dörfern gesehen wie
viele menschen sind ohne zuhause und wo
stecken jetzt
ja beelitz war der erste ort der
teilweise evakuiert werden musste als
man jetzt heute morgen durch durch den
ort gefahren das hat man schon menschen
gesehen aber eben nur im bereich der
weiter entfernt ist vom wald es gibt
hier einige straßen die gestern komplett
evakuiert werden mussten da mussten
einige hundert menschen aus ihren
häusern raus die wurden teilweise
gebeten sich in eine stadthalle in
treuenbrietzen zu begeben und sich dort
zu versammeln also es gibt hier
notunterkünfte für die menschen wo sie
erst mal untergebracht werden aber das
ist natürlich also wenn man hier aus
seinem haus quasi rausgeschickt wird von
einem auf den anderen moment
gesagt wird es waldbrandgefahr alles
zurücklassen raus einfach nur raus und
so schnell wie möglich in diese
notunterkünfte das ist natürlich eine
enorme stresssituation für die menschen
gestern gewesen und sie hoffen natürlich
darauf dass sie so schnell wie möglich
wieder zurück in ihre häuser können
jetzt sehen wir hinter dir gerade
rauschte der wasserwerfer von der
polizei vorbei also auch die polizei
dort mit diesen riesigen fahrzeugen im
einsatz um vom rande aus zu löschen wald
hinein noch eine letzte frage klarer
brandstiftung gibt es irgendeine andere
erklärung für diese feuer als
brandstiftung und natürlich die frage
wer macht so was
diese die diese extreme hitze die wir in
den letzten tagen hier erlebt haben 37
grad waren es gestern die befeuern
natürlich im wahrsten sinne des wortes
ja so ein feuer im wald das dann auch
ganz schnell und wendig wird und eben da
diese situation in den wäldern hier in
brandenburg die ja auch schon seit
einigen jahren so ist also dass diese
flächen teilweise vermieden sind nicht
geräumt werden auch teilweise aus
kostengründen weil es einfach zu teuer
wäre da regelmäßige sprengungen
kontrollierte sprengungen durchzuführen
und diese wälder von diesem jahr von der
munition zu befreien das ist ja eine
situation die wir schon seit jahren
haben also immer wieder im sommer brennt
es hier und immer wieder können die
polizei nicht in die welt erfahren
aufgrund dieser situation und da ist
natürlich also fragt man sich wie das in
den nächsten jahren werden soll wenn die
situation so bleibt wie sie jetzt ist